called cryptography.
Cryptography is the study of how to secure communication,
and it's about two really important things:
masking information so it can be hidden in plain sight,
and verifying a piece of information's source.
Cryptography underpins so many of the systems around us.
And it's so powerful that at times
the US government has actually classified it as a weapon.
During World War II, breaking cryptosystems like Enigma
was critical to decoding enemy transmissions
and turning the tide of the war.
Today, anyone with a modern web browser is running
a pretty sophisticated cryptosystem.
It's what we use to secure our interactions on the Internet.
It's what makes it safe for us to type our passwords in
and to send financial information to websites.
So what the banks used to give us --
trustworthy digital money transfer --
we can now get with a clever application of cryptography.
And this means that we don't have to rely on the banks anymore
to secure our transactions.
We can do it ourselves.
Bitcoin is based on the very same idea that the Yap used,
this collective global knowledge of transfers.
In Bitcoin, I spend by transferring Bitcoin,
and I get paid when someone transfers Bitcoin to me.
Imagine that we had this magic paper.
So the way that this paper works is I can give you a sheet of it
and if you write something on it,
it will magically appear on my piece as well.
Let's say we just give everyone this paper
and everyone writes down the transfers that they're doing
in the Bitcoin system.
All of these transfers get copied around to everyone else's pieces of paper.
And I can look at mine
and I'll have a list of all of the transfers that are happening
in the entire Bitcoin economy.
This is actually what's happening with the Bitcoin blockchain,
which is a list of all of the transactions in Bitcoin.
Except, it's not done through paper.
It's done through computer code,
running on thousands of networked computers
around the world.
All of these computers are collectively confirming
who owns what Bitcoin.
So the Bitcoin blockchain is core to how Bitcoin works.
But where do bitcoins actually come from?
Well, the code is designed to create new Bitcoin
according to a schedule.
And the way that it works is that to get those Bitcoin,
I have to solve a puzzle -- a random cryptographic puzzle.
Imagine that we had 15 dice,
and we were throwing these dice over and over again.
Whenever the dice come up all sixes,
we say that we win.
This is very close to what these computers are all actually doing.
They're trying over and over again to land on the right number.
And when they do,
we say that they've solved the puzzle.
The computer that solves the puzzle
publishes its solution to the rest of the network
and collects its reward: new bitcoins.
And in the act of solving this puzzle,
these computers are actually helping to secure the Bitcoin blockchain
and add to the list of transactions.
There are actually people all over the world running this software,
and we call them Bitcoin miners.
Anyone can become a Bitcoin miner.
You can go download the software right now
and run it in your computer and try to collect some bitcoins.
I can't say that I would recommend it,
because right now, the puzzle is so hard and the network is so powerful,
that if I tried to mine Bitcoin on my laptop,
I probably wouldn't see any for about two million years.
The miners, professional miners, use this special hardware
that's designed to solve the puzzle really fast.
Now, the Bitcoin network and all of this special hardware,
there are estimates that the amount of energy it uses
is equivalent to that of a small country.
So, the first set of cryptocurrencies
are a little bit slow and a little bit cumbersome.
But the next generation is going to be so much better and so much faster.
Cryptocurrencies are the first step
to a world with a global programmable money.
And in a world with programmable money,
I can pay anyone else securely
without having to sign up or ask permission,
or do a conversion or worry about my money getting stuck.
And I can send money around the world.
This is a really amazing thing.
It's the idea of permission-less innovation.
The Internet caused an explosion of innovation,
because it was built upon an open architecture.
And just like the Internet changed the way we communicate,
programmable money is going to change the way we pay,
allocate and decide on value.
So what kind of world does programmable money create?
Imagine a world where I can rent out my healthcare data
to a pharmaceutical company.
They can run large-scale data analysis
and provide me with a cryptographic proof
that shows they're only using my data in a way that we agreed.
And they can pay me for what they find out.
Instead of signing up for streaming services
and getting a cable bill,
what if my television analyzed my watching habits
and recommended well-priced content that fit within my budget
that I would enjoy?
Imagine an Internet without ads,
because instead of paying with our attention when we view content,
we just pay.
Interestingly, things like micro-payments
are actually going to change the way security works in our world,
because once we're better able to allocate value,
people will use their money and their energies
for more constructive things.
If it cost a fraction of a cent to send an email,
would we still have spam?
We're not at this world yet,
but it's coming.
Right now, it's like we're in a world that is seeing the first automobile.
The first cryptocurrency, like the first car,
is slow and hard to understand and hard to use.
Digital money, like the horse and carriage,
works pretty well,
and the whole world economy is built on it.
If you were the first person on your block
to get a car with an internal combustion engine,
your neighbors would probably think you were crazy:
"Why would you want this large, clunky machine
that breaks down all the time, that lights on fire,
and is still slower than a horse?"
But we all know how that story turns out.
We're entering a new era of programmable money.
And it's very exciting, but it's also a little bit scary.
Cryptocurrencies can be used for illegal transactions,
just like cash is used for crime in the world today.
When all of our transactions are online,
what does that mean for surveillance -- who can see what we do?
Who's advantaged in this new world and who isn't?
Will I have to start to pay for things that I didn't have to pay for before?
Will we all become slaves to algorithms and utility functions?
All new technology comes with trade-offs.
The Internet brought us a lot of ways to waste time.
But it also greatly increased productivity.
Mobile phones are annoying
because they make me feel like I have to stay connected to work
all the time.
But they also help me stay connected to friends and family.
The new sharing economy is going to eliminate some jobs.
But it's also going to create new, flexible forms of employment.
With programmable money,
we decouple the need for large, trusted institutions
from the architecture of the network.
And this pushes innovation in money out to the edges, where it belongs.
Programmable money democratizes money.
And because of this, things are going to change and unfold
in ways that we can't even predict.
Thank you.
(Applause)